تطبيق تحرير الصور لمسه اي اي شهد اقبالا
هائلا في الاونه الاخيره رغم اطلاقه منذ
عام 28
فالعديد من المشاهير والمؤثرين من مختلف
الدول العالم نشروا صورهم باستخدام
التطبيق عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
المختلفه هذه الميزان شهد تفاعلا واسعا
تستخدم ذكاء الاصطناعي لتحرير الصور على
نحو غير مسبوق حيث تعالج ما بين 10 الى 20
صوره شخصيه بواسطه نموذج الذكر الصناعي
عمليه قد تستغرق نحو 40 دقيقه في مسقعه
منها لمعالجه مخاوف الخصوصيه تقي- تقولوا
الشركه التي اطلقت تطبيق ان صور
المستخدمين الشخصيه والنموذج بالصله تحذف
نهائيا من خوامها ثوره انشاء الصور رمزيه
الصحيه الا عن الخبراء يرون ان التطبيقه
ينتهي كوك حقوق النشر وبحسب واشنطوس تطبيق
يزيد المخاطر الاستغلال وتحرش خاصه انه
يسمح لاي شخص لتنزيل صور اشخاص اخرين
بفضل ميزات الصور الرمزيه السحريه حديث
تطبيق لنزه خلال شهر نوفمبر الماضي وحده
على نحو 1.6 مليون عمليه تنزيل والان وصل
اجمالي عدد مرات تنزيل التطبيق الى 20
مليون هذا يعني ان تطبيق حظيع بمعدل نمو
بلغت نسبته 600 في المئه بعد اختيار
الصوره يطلب التطبيق من المستخدم دفع
الرسوم اللازمه لانشاء صوره الرمزيه
السحريه والتي تبدا من 3.99 دولار امريكي
وذلك حسب العدد المطلوب الذي ياتي في ثلاث
خيارات او 100 صوره او 100 صوره وبناء على
عدد السور المختار تبدا عمليه المعالجه
بواسطه نموذج الذكاء الاصطناعي المفتوح
المصدر المسمى الانتشار المستقبل والتي
تستغرق من 20 الى 40 دقيقه ويوفر التطبيق
هذه العمليه من خلال منصه الحوسبه
السحابيه التابعه لاما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للمزيد ينضم الينا من الرياض
يعني تطبيق لاقرا وارجع كبيرا يعالج الصور
الشخصيه بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي لماذا
لقى كل هذا الرواج وحدثنا اكثر
اول شيء الله يعطيكم العافيه وصباح الخير
عليكم جميعا التطبيق فكرتها فكره بسيطه
جدا انه يحول الصور يعالجها ويقدمها
المستخدمين وفي التطبيقات كثيره اساسا
تقدم مثل هذه الخدمه باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي يعني في تطبيقات اساسا موجوده
مجرد ما تيجي وتطلب منها بالكتابه مثلا
تقدر تقول له احتاج صوره شخص مثلا جالس
على كرسي يستمتع بالبحر يبدا دكاله
الصناعيه يبدا يرسم لك تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لمعالجه الصور ما هي همم
جديده بالعكس هي تطبيقات قديمه لكنه كل
تطبيق ياخذ رواتب كل فتره لانه يستخدم من
قبل الاشخاص معينين في منصات التواصل
اجتماعيه ويفضلوا الناس انهم يقتدون فيهم
يستخدمون نفس التطبيق اللي هم كانوا
يستخدمونه
من خلال الناس اللي على السوشيال ميديا
لحظه انه الصور اللي نزلوها من خلال
همم الاي اي ار تي فشل انتلجنس صاروا احلى
اشكالهم صراحه حقيقه يعني
سلافات نظري انه اجسادهم صارت مختلفه وهذا
امر خطير قد يكون تركيب الصور في المستقبل
على جسد امراه يعني لا تشبه الامراه التي
نراها في الحقيقه
يمكن اي شخص حاليا قادر انه يغير في ملامح
الجسد ملامح الوجه همم تطبيقات مثل تيك
توك سناب شات تعتمد على الواقع المعزز
والفلاثر الخاصه فيها تخلي الصغير كبير
صغير وهذه موجوده زي المدونه الصينيه اللي
كانت
تطلعين وبعدها يوم راح الفلتر بتسوي لها
كبيره جدا في العمر مختلفه عن الصوره اللي
تطلع لهم مياهها الذكاء الاصطناعي اساسا
هو وسيله من الوسائل اللي موجوده اجتماعيه
او حتى في الانترنت الاستفاده منها من
التطبيقات المختلفه وهذه التطبيقات اللي
موجوده واللي تقدر انت ممكن تستخدمها
تغيير الجسد تغيير الملامح تغيير الوجه هو
شيء قديم موجود حتى من قبل ظهور الصناعي
لكن اصطناعي سهل فقط العمليه الاكبر من
هذه التقنيه عبد الله كان صور الشخصيه
تطبيق هل هناك ضماناتنا ان تحذف الصور
الشخصيه من خوادم الشركه بعد معالجتها
من الان الناس اللي تبحث عن الخصوصيه
وتستخدم الانترنت يقول لها طفوا الانترنت
تجلسوا في البيت عندكم اما انك انت عندك
تخوف من شيء معين لا تستخدمه نهائيا لان
حتى لو سياسه التطبيق قالت لنا ما راح
تستخدم الصور او ما راح تستفيد منها او
غيرها هل تضمن ان ما راح يكون في اختراق
الخدمه ما راح يكون في تسريب للخدمه وغيره
هذه مواضيع صراحه جدا كبيره نرجع ونقول ان
موضوع الخصوصيه موضوع الخطاب اذا انت تخاف
من شيء اتجاهها لو لا تسويه
طيب عبد الله اليوم كمان لاحظنا انه جوده
هذه الصور وتعطي جماليات وتبرز العيون
وهكذا لماذا لا يتم تصنيع هواتف بكاميرات
بتعمل بنفس جوده ما تقوم به التطبيقات
اول شيء الجوال اللي في يدك حاليا في نفس
هذا الموضوع مجرد تطبيق بسيط تنزلينا على
الجوال يمديك تستخدمين نفس هذه الميزه
يمديك تغيري لها اساسا الان عيادات
التجميل بدات تستخدم مثل هذه الافكار
لوضعها في الهواتف الذكيه فانت مجرد ما
تدخل تستخدم تطبيق معين يقول لك انت قادر
انك تعدل كذا تسوي كذا وغيره فالموضوع
يعني قديم
شايف ما سوا خير في الجميع
لو سمحتوا نقص من الفلاتر والتطبيقات لانه
كثر الخطابين مصدومين عبد الله السبعه ههه
شكرا